demand for housing in Washington DC is
going through the roof over a thousand
people move into the city every month
driving up the cost of housing and
they're turning the nation's capital
into a construction zone tower cranes
piercing the sky above the city's
streets have become so common they're
just part of the background but as fast
as the cranes have gone up demand for
housing is rising even faster making DC
among the most expensive places to live
in the United States and one innovation
whose time has come
shows just why the demand for housing is
far from being met iconic I've driven
down the tiny-house Road because of
affordability simplicity sustainability
and then mobility Tony once's are very
cheap to build though you can build one
of these for $10,000 you can build one
for 30 40 $50,000 but they definitely
come in far beneath the cost of a
regular home especially in a city like
DC they're very sustainable they take a
very little energy to heat or cool so
having a space that I could hook up to
solar that I could you know catch
rainwater and I use for a simple shower
and sink I was very very appealing to me
they are mobile because many of them are
built on wheels and the reason they're
often built on wheels is because it then
escapes a lot of the kind of coding
requirements which these homes would
violate not because they're unsafe
places to live but because the minimum
size of a of a room you know must be 120
square feet and if these homes are 120
square feet all together you
then have you no obvious obvious issues
this is not a tiny house it's the office
of zoning the Zoning Commission the
Zoning Administrator the Board of Zoning
adjustment and the office of planning
which along with the Department of
consumer and regulatory affairs
implements adjudicates and enforces 34
chapters and 600 pages of regulations
governing property use and building
requirements in the nation's capital the
director of the cities office of
planning ellen mccarthy described the
problem with allowing tiny houses in the
city we need some level of controls so
people aren't setting up squatter camps
in alleys we're trying to recognize that
people's situations require a variety of
different living arrangements and so the
zoning authorities have allowed a few
experiments in affordable housing like
this apartment made entirely from
shipping containers but the city is
constrained by a zoning ordinance that
was drawn up in 1958 that's 56 years of
cultural change and building innovations
like tiny houses that the code wasn't
designed to address and for small
builders like Jay Austin getting a
special exemption from the zoning
authorities could cost tens of thousands
of dollars and years of time with no
guarantee of success we proposed changes
the zoning rewrite won't affect what
we're doing at all we are tiny-home the
wheels are still a little bit further
out probably many years out decades out
it's totally legal to buy one of these
and to park it somewhere and really it
only becomes illegal once you
potentially illegal once you step inside
and say this is my home we can leave
these houses on the lot I imagine for 20
years and there wouldn't be any issue
with it but if we declared these are
full-time residences and then there you
know would be a little bit more a little
bit more trouble perhaps the laws that
keep Jay Austin from living in his own
home have their genesis in new york
city's zoning resolution of 1916 for the
first time in history committees of
urban planners began to reshape an
entire american city they split up
skyscrapers to provide more sunlight on
the streets below
industrial factories were separated from
residential property immigrant
communities were kept apart from
neighborhoods of the elite and when the
Supreme Court ruled these laws didn't
violate property rights zoning quickly
spread to every major city in America
every city that is except for one
Houston for me is an experiment it's an
experiment in in overt capitalism and
therefore very much at home in Texas
there is a kind of libertarian way of
thinking here it's much more alive in a
way much more organic than a typical
zone city that is more restricted by
these very old-fashioned measures that
no longer are viable if you live in an
unsung City you have to develop a
dialogue of negotiation and that of
course we have seen in our country is
not easy to come by
I have architect friends they have to
operate in places like Berkeley where
their Zoning Board you know it's sort of
like a group of estheticians without
training and say no that's no good this
is good this is Berkeley this is not and
this sort of you know it's silliness but
has enormous economic consequence is
operating in those places while here you
can always get away with anything
anything like a house clad entirely in
beer cans in Houston a few simple laws
govern lot sizes and setbacks from the
street there's even a new Historical
Preservation ordinance but for the most
part developments are regulated by
private covenants and deed restrictions
and without city codes committees or
planners to regulate land use all sorts
of creative expression are possible when
architects began to build homes out of
corrugated metal a cheap material
associated with poverty and trailer
parks no one had the authority to stop
them as it turned out not only were ten
houses economical they also kept homes
cool by reflecting sunlight during
Houston's sweltering summers
today 10 houses are cherished as a
unique houston innovation whether it's a
tin house in Houston or McMansion in
McAllen homes in the sprawling state of
Texas will always be cheaper than the
densely populated Northeast but compared
to the rest of the Sun Belt where cities
are zoned and the land is plentiful
unregulated Houston is still the most
affordable large city in America I
totally agree that regulation is about
preventing bad things from happening
houston success in creating affordable
housing for the middle-class is one
reason why the city is disparaged by the
one group whose job it makes obsolete
urban planners like Harriet Tregoning
formerly of the Washington DC office of
planning I hate to make Houston the
whipping boy right go ahead no that's a
place that doesn't have dawning it
doesn't have regulation and it's not
exactly the full flower of you know of
urbanism two hours down the Gulf Coast
from Houston is Victoria a city that
hasn't had zoning since it was founded a
hundred and ninety years ago and the
most unusual thing about Victoria is
that it's not very unusual at all I
don't notice anything greatly different
about Victoria and the look that
Victoria portrays and the look that they
have in San Antonio Austin or Houston so
property rights in Texas are sacred you
can do what you want to do with your
with your property and and I think most
of the people here in Victoria want to
protect that right the city growth and
land use is based more on economics in
the will of the owner rather than some
quasi governmental body that you have to
ask permission from east of town was a
rendering plant where they took dead
animals and processed them the people
that were in favor of zoning would say
well what if there's a rendering plant
next to your house economics dictate
that you're not going to put a rent
plant next to a residential subdivision
economics dictates that you're going to
build a shopping center on a major
thoroughfare it's worked very well in
Victoria for a number of years and I
trust will continue to do so now it's
true if you look hard enough in Victoria
or in Houston you can find the odd
high-rise poking out of a low-density
neighborhood and sometimes economics
dictates that you'll have to eat your
butterscotch dilly bar next to the bail
bondsman but tolerating a little
disharmony a dash of kitsch and the
occasional strip club in a strip mall
along the Texas Gulf Coast is a small
down payment on the right to be the
architect of your own life
because of your Jay Aston you can build
the home of your dreams you just can't
live there for now his tiny house is a
part-time residence and a full-time
showpiece to present to the public in
the hopes of changing a zoning committee
that hasn't updated a zoning code in 56
years
you